non-minimalists
i don't know how to get in the mindset
of consumerism
that is a minimalistic i
can see it afterwards i can see the
after effects of it but i can't
have a minimalistic mindset in the
moment how can i get that mindset
how can i go day to day throughout my
week
and not need to declutter every
saturday and sunday when i look at all
of the things that i've accumulated
throughout the week
so ryan what i'm thinking about with
nicole here
is the best offense is a good defense
and i'm thinking of like some of the
most well-rounded teams in sports i i'm
a basketball fan you're a football fan
and
neither one of us know much about the
the other sport right
but battle shot right yeah good job
and and uh safety yeah
all right so what i'm thinking about
here is
there are some players james harden who
plays for the houston rockets
is is a good example he is probably the
best offensive player
see the guy with the beard yes yeah
we've seen him in
live in a game in houston and so he has
that he's got the giant beard
and he's probably the best offensive
player in the game
he may even be some people will argue
he's the best offensive player of all
time
he's really really great at offense he's
not a very good defensive player
this is nicole nicole is great at office
i'm great at decluttering i've got that
mindset i can let go
easily by the way letting go is a
superpower nicole congratulations you
have formed a superpower but
what's going to make you better is if
you get a good defense because you have
to let go
less frequent in fact not buying
something is simply
letting it go in advance i love that
tweet that podcast sean
so so ryan let's talk about i mean there
are obviously some rules that we could
we could give
nicole here but she used a word i want
to talk about first
that she she used i can't get into the
consumerism mindset well that's the
problem you're in
the consumerism mindset
there's nothing wrong with consumption
we all need some stuff the problem is
consumerism did she say something like
she said something about the minimalist
version of consumerism mindset which
sounded like an oxymoron to me it is
yeah yeah
so a minimalist consumes intentionally
we do some things whether it's
buying things locally buying fewer
things
uh buying things that have multiple uses
investing more in experiences than in
stuff
but making sure that everything that we
own she uses the words
adds value what does that mean it means
it serves a purpose or brings me joy
now serving a purpose means it has some
sort of function brings me
joy doesn't just mean it brings me
pleasure don't mistake and that that's
where
where nicole is right now she gets
pleasure from consuming these things
that's consumerism i don't care about
your pleasure with respect to
stuff what i want you to get from things
is a function or joy joy means sharing
experiences with other people that
amplify
or enhance your life overall and so
she's here right now in the space where
she's like i'm great
at offense i can get rid of everything
my trouble is
i can't stop the things from coming in
yeah i've got a few rules yeah i wonder
what she's telling herself like because
i'm imagining
she comes across something she wants to
buy and she's telling herself like
well i'll go ahead and buy it because
it's going to give me that dopamine rush
you know
because if i ultimately have to let go
of it i'll just let go of it
so it's like this excuse of letting go
to buy something
is i don't know i don't know what's
going through her mind but that's what i
imagine
is probably one of the things going
through her mind but yeah how do we help
her build
a defense towards thoughts like that
well she's got a dichotomy then right
because if she's
if she has that line of thinking i agree
with you it's probably there
where i can just get rid of this later
but then she hates having to continue to
declutter right
yeah well here's what i'll say a couple
things minimalism is a horizon you will
get there
but then there's always a new horizon
you don't actually get to
the horizon and so you do have to
continue to be
intentional with the things that you
hold on to because the things that add
value today may stop adding value and
then
you're going to have to let them go at
some point otherwise you're just
hoarding clutter at that point
however that's going to happen less
frequently if you do have a good
defense so a couple rules that stand out
to me right away these are also both
from
the minimalist rule book the 16 rules
for living with less
one that really stands out is the 30 30
rule because
that's the rule that really stops the
impulse shopping we also call it the
wait for it rule right
and so if something costs more than 30
you wait at least 30 hours to buy
the thing now if it's more than 100
bucks i try to wait
30 days and what that does it just puts
some distance
some friction in between you and that
purchase because it's easier than ever
now especially with
one-click shopping yeah i mean i can get
it right now and we live in
we live in los angeles if i in fact i
don't even have to click anymore i just
imagine it and it shows up on my
doorstep yeah in like four minutes yeah
that's crazy and the problem is when we
have that much
we we get rid of that much friction we
get rid of all the friction we lose
traction and that's where
where is she's lost traction so she's
sliding all over the place
one other rule that i think will really
help out with consumption is the
the one in ten out rule
now this is modeled after the sort of
building capacity if you go to a
nightclub and they're like sorry we're
at capacity right
now we're seeing this with coronavirus
now you go to the grocery store sorry
it's like we're at capacity
well this is that rule but on steroids
every time you bring something into your
house you have to get rid of ten items
now you could adjust that you could do
one in five out if you have way too much
stuff you can do one in a hundred out
right but the the key is that it makes
you start to think about
those things you bring into your home
because you know if i want one shirt
well 10 things from my closet have to
leave that closet before i can bring
the one thing in and all of a sudden you
start looking at your new purchases a
little bit
differently because they have a lot more
weight to them
yeah yeah i think uh she needs to come
up with some rules herself and yeah the
rule book is a great place to start
because yeah that's our recipe but she
can create her own recipe but the fact
is that she needs to come up with a
recipe to help her curb those impulses
yes indeed nicole i'm sending you a copy
of our book essential
ryan and i wrote three books together
other than the the free ebook
but uh we have three long-form books one
of them is called essential so
we have three books one is a a why two
book there's a a
what two book that's minimalism and then
the how to book is essential it's an
essay collection
12 areas of intentional living i'll hold
it up if you're watching it on
youtube by the way we've got a new
youtube channel now uh youtube.com the
minimalist podcast it's separated from
our
main youtube channel so you can
subscribe to either one of those
either slash the minimalist or slash the
minimalist podcast the the other channel
the other minimalism channel
uh is just the minimalists and they're
more minimalist videos yeah they're
short bursts of minimalism right
and youtube encouraged us they basically
said hey look we
are we fake our site favors consistency
and so put your shorter videos on one
channel put your long podcasts on a
separate channel
and that way your message will reach
more eyes and ears
anyway nicole i'm gonna send you a copy
of essential if you like
our podcast i think you'll really like
the audiobook version of essentials our
longest book it's over six hours long
or if you want the book book or the
ebook version happy to send those
to you as well